foreign
people can feel authenticity and that's
what you know people relate to
everyone's just trying to feel connected
and I think that's like what I try to do
is just put myself out there how I am
I started when I was seven years old my
older brother was playing drums at the
time and I wanted to play an instrument
too when I saw him playing an instrument
and I kind of just chose bass and I just
like never looked back I just fell in
love with the instrument and just that
was it from there
to the pandemic my audience grew like
super I guess way faster than I would
have thought I mean performing is my
favorite thing in the world my favorite
feeling like best feeling I can ever
get and when that kind of stopped I had
to look at you know other avenues of
of getting that same sort of feeling or
at least just like
yeah playing to some sort of audience so
I started just kind of like
performing for my phone and posting that
online just videos of me playing and
practicing and those videos of me
playing bass resonated with people and
inspired people and that's kind of how I
got to like connect in a different way
the fact that I play bass as a young
woman is you know more rare and
definitely like sets me apart I didn't
really see it at the time when I was
growing up
and that always kind of like set me
apart I never really saw any other women
especially like female front woman who
played bass when I was starting I had
people say that like no one cared about
the bass and I should like stop focusing
on that and like all that stuff and that
was just not
you know that's not what I believed in
that was like my passion it can get
really distracting with there's a lot of
people around you kind of telling you
what they think you should do or what
you should do so I think just like
staying true to your path and true to
like your truth I guess living your
truth and just
yeah just do your thing
I think the most challenging part is
just the ups and downs there's a lot of
highs and lows with being an artist
being in any industry but especially
being being an artist and and Performing
it's you know it's not all glamorous and
there's a lot of hard work that needs to
be you know put in so I think just like
dealing with the highs and lows of
performing and then traveling and doing
all these things you definitely have to
keep the creative battery charged and
kind of like remind yourself
why you do it in the first place I think
that's what I do every time I feel like
drained or anything I just remember how
grateful I am that I get to do this for
my life and that kind of like fuels me
and also just like connecting with
people all the time
performing and and um getting that
connection between the fans I think also
like refuels my my battery to keep going
and keep putting music out and keep
performing
[Music]
I see flipping to the business side as
just a way of expanding
my passion and sharing that with more
people
I think that's kind of what like
entrepreneurship is about is like
turning your passion into that into that
business and showing other people that
they can do it too you know if I can do
it
you could do it just always do your best
and always learn from the people around
you and surround yourself with people
that are almost better than you and
that's how you get better I think that's
something that I that I took really
strongly growing up and just practice
too and just like
to work hard also taking time for
yourself and just making sure that
you're
you're feeling good mentally is the most
you know one of the most important
things too
I just want to inspire and Empower and
if anyone's inspired by me to like pick
up the base or pick up an instrument or
follow their passion that's like the
best I think Legacy I could leave
[Music]